this is supposed to be a jeff goldblum
gold bloom praise session okay well i
love him so much yeah he doesn't have to
know who we are you know
and he does that says a lot of let me
ask you a question uh ladies love that
man love him and i understand because
you know again we have a similar frame
okay don't do that don't
i don't understand why you go down there
no but i don't understand like not i can
handle it i can handle it why is it that
the there's a fork in the road
swagger yeah geez you know how like at a
time porsche and volkswagen had the same
engine
that's the difference
it's also
it's like
no i can handle it i really want to know
he is a chill
person who seems very comfortable in his
skin and very confident not that you're
not but it seems like he's been that way
much longer than you have i don't know
and i went through a very like awkward
phase where you were like oh i don't
like myself no
was that that was that was that's no but
what i'm saying is that it does it does
amaze me that he does have something
that i wish i had that i don't have oh
me too you know and and uh i'm being
completely honest he has
he does have an ease and he's always in
the center he's always centered i think
that's incredible to be centered like
that all the time and he's he's like a
tuning fork that's perfectly vibrating
with the universe
and um i feel like i'm a
you know like uh you're just a fork yeah
like a fork yeah that was eating clams
but someone didn't wash it afterwards
and then it fell in some sand and it's
got some clam juice and sand on it
that's pretty good yeah do you think
we like him because he's nice to us oh
maybe if you tried being nice to me and
matt then we would like mom maybe still
not you good
you got a paycheck right that's not
being nice to someone then you gotta pay
you i'm your employee that doesn't mean
you're nice to me it's kind of worse
because it's like you're paying her to
be belligerent you the fact that you
even thought you make it do you do okay
i do yeah i do would you say that uh
i mean are there a lot of other people
just sending you money besides me nobody
else's
then i'm a good guy and i'm your friend
no that doesn't sound how nice this is
it's not transactions
jeff goldblum asks nothing and gives
everything you you got a paycheck from
you you you why are you
no i've seen you driving since the
podcast blew up and suddenly you're
driving a bentley no yes you're driving
a bentley on uh you know just on
hollywood boulevard yeah you know
classic girls yeah and and oh your
license plate suddenly pod king
and you're driving around you guys have
both pod king is seven yeah
and your kids were these like crazy
satin outfits that you have handmade for
them now that the podcast blew up and so
both of you have your lives have been
changed by knowing me which means you
have to like me you have to you know
that's not how it works it should work
that way and buy a friendship that's
nice just you can no you can't that's
why i moved to los angeles but you can't
no you can sona and i are two
friends genuinely like all of my friends
work for me and i'm very comfortable
with that because if any of them piss me
off i can terminate that friendship very
easily i wonder why we like jeff
goldblum more than you
i still don't understand he's my
favorite tall person and he just exudes
this like sense of ease and you know
what he doesn't have to pay me for me to
like him yeah and that says a lot hmm
this is interesting i have to look more
into this into friendship
just to the
he leads with love you lead with fear
yes no stalin did that yeah i know he
controlled
it stalin joseph stalin oh
so now we're gonna rip on joseph stalin
you know
i love how there's no secret there's no
sacred cows anymore everybody gets torn
down everybody gets torn
jesus no one's safe in this
hyper-sensitive area
yeah yeah um he's an angel yeah he's an
absolute angel he's a such a sweet
person he might be an alien
he is you know he is you know we should
stick the landing on this he is uh such
an unusually
he's an unusual person there's no one
else quite like him and i do have to
tell you that when i in my travels
people always bring up to me oh my god i
love it when jeff goldblum is on the
podcast where he's on the show
um
he brings an energy that immediately
transforms the experience
i think we all are changed by him when
we're in his he creates like a biosphere
a jeff goldblum biosphere that's very
enjoyable yeah yeah and he he remembers
everybody he's just he like when he
looks at you he looks at you and he
knows your name and he remembers you and
that goes along yeah but i don't again i
have
a list of all the employees i can
consult
i can go to jeff ross i can go to jeff
frost now i don't need to
all i have to do is go to jeff ross for
adam sacks and say the guy with the
you know he's kind of a hipster and he
lives in pasadena and they'll be like
yeah matt gourley and i'll be like yeah
yeah yeah yeah anyway tell him i wished
him a happy christmas
i got to get out of here my helicopter
my helicopter's waiting it's me
wait what yeah my helicopter's waiting
that's your hulk
god your helicopter is ill yeah
wait wait how does the helicopter
no but mine is different mine runs on
pure malice
it's very eco-friendly
it's super pervy somehow
is wow mr brian you must really hate
people today we've got 600 000 miles
i just get in it and put an electrode on
my head
and it leaves a noxious cloud of just
pure bad intent metaphorically that's
what's going on here all right well
anyway jeff goldblum uh if you're
listening right now yes naked in the
lotus position
as you as you meditate as he does every
night
uh
we love you